so uh
i am raghavindran lakshmi narayan i'm a
research consultant and bioinformatics
mentor with bind biology uh it's very uh
it's wonderful to see you all and
welcome to this session
i'm trained in bioinformatics and i hold
a computational biology phd degree from
max prank institute germany so my
research interest and focus
is on the application of variety of data
science techniques such as machine
learning approaches deep learning
approaches towards the translational
studies of cancer biology towards
applying to plant genetics and
neurological disorder etc so my role in
this company includes mentoring a
variety of students like you students
who are from high school students who
are from bachelor's students were doing
masters and all the way up to students
who are pursuing phds
so
please let me introduce you about my
background and how we started in the
field of bioinformatics research
so the impact of human genome project in
a variety of biological research field
is very well known and documented so in
fact this very discussion that we are
having and the meeting is a result of
this extraordinary project
so this project affected my career as
well so when the findings of human
genome research project was announced
and its promise inspired me
to pursue a
career in biology
from
from jumping fields from being a
physicist
so i completed my master's in uh
biophysics and bioinformatics being
under graduation in uh being under
undergraduate in uh physics and followed
by which i joined max planck institute
in germany to
work on my phd thesis
so after that my two postdoctoral
research tenures from india from
institute of bioinformatics and applied
biotechnology bengaluru and jawaharlal
nehru university
this is where um it was instrumental in
helping me develop a deeper
understanding
in the
in the area of bioinformatics research
applications to variety of different
data sets so for the past eight months i
am part of this wonderful company which
gives me opportunity to share my
learning to inspiring students like you
so over the course of my career or over
the course of my tenure i have been
involved in projects from variety of
different backgrounds that includes
protein structural biology that includes
agriculture uh that includes multi-omics
data analysis like uh genomics
transcriptomics epigenomics data et
cetera and these are mixed data are
quite from a variety of different
sources like model systems
like from patient resources unlike from
agricultural sources and etc so this
variety of projects and this
wide spectrum has been immensely helpful
for me to tending to students with a
wide range of interest and in
in pursuing research training with
us so to give you an idea of uh
of my research uh interest and
background give let me share one of the
interesting projects that i was involved
in
during my career
so this is a project on precision
oncology and to introduce you to
precision oncology uh first let me tell
that
most of you would have already known
oncology is a study of cancer biology
and we know that cancer is a leading
cause of disease states worldwide for
such a dreadful disease and for disease
with such an impact um
systematic carrier treatments have
relied on drugs which are
chemotherapeutic drugs and these drugs
are marginally more toxic to the cancer
cells than normal studies i mean such an
approach is not very ideal and it gives
us our results in a huge problem
because on an average only 25 percentage
of the cancer patients respond
positively to these cancer products but
in comparison over 80 percentage of the
patients respond to popular painkillers
like
aspirin that you get over the count
so one of the prominent solution to this
problem is precision ontology so
precision ontological therapy is is a is
a strategy
where the treatment is actually designed
by targeting the molecular
characteristics of the patient's tumor
so hence the treatment that is given to
the patients are personalized to the
to those patients who are likely to
respond to specific therapies and
therapeutic approaches
so the way that we have approached or
the way that i have addressed this
precision oncological
problem issue
is to implement data-driven approaches
to include multi-omics data for
understanding and for predicting
patients response to a variety of cancer
treatments
so how do i do this
the tumor cells that that form cancer in
patients are
collected in during biopsy
and are then subjected to next
generation sequencing techniques and the
information about
gene expression the information about a
mutation and the information about
epigenetic variation that characterizes
the gene expression were extracted and
they were recorded
this data or these omics data
molecularly characterizes the tumor so
these are different from from
different types of tumor and different
subtypes of human and then these tumor
samples are then
grafted or then administered
several cancer drugs and their response
is studied by
measuring their bond
so this data records the tumors reaction
and response to different treatments
some for some treatments the tumor will
diminish in volume and for some of the
treatments it will not uh respond
positively so these responses and the
molecular
characterization data characterize data
were then integrated and various
machine learning algorithms and deep
learning algorithms were applied to
understand how they are related so from
this relationship we were able to
predict which patient or which cancer
from which patients
were able to positively or will be able
to respond positively to the treatment
that is that they are subjected to or
from the list of multiple treatments so
this is how we approach
understanding cancer biology from
multi-org data different approaches
so projects like these and various other
projects and
example projects methodologies and
resources are compiled and explained
expertly in the learn omix logic
platform so while you are enrolled in
specific programs that addresses your
interest you are also welcome to explore
various such resources under example
projects and expand your horizons in the
field of bioinformatics data analysis
so as i have already mentioned my main
involvement in this
is with the students
who are enrolled with research
fellowship program
this research fellowship program is
designed to address key challenges that
every student will face
while
subjecting or while opting for a
bioinformatic research so if you are
interested in extending your enrollment
for research fellowship program after
the completion of your specific program
then you would also
be able to leverage all the resources
that are developed to overcome these key
challenges like
time involved in learning and testing
out a lot of different strategies
and time and access to bioinformatics
expertise and access to
big data infrastructure
so
who will benefit from a research
fellowship program like this and who
what will the students like you take
away
from these research fellowship program
so for students who are new to
bioinformatics and who does not have an
early exposure to bioinformatics this
gives you an excellent opportunity to
develop an exposure to the methods to
the logic behind these methods and
analysis and to practice your knowledge
that we have gained
throughout this program
into a research project that interests
you or research project that will help
you in your care
and for students who have some exposure
to bioinformatics and who already know a
little bit of bioinformatics you will
gain expert feedback and project
evaluation
that will take your project from a
superficial investigation
to
superficial investigation
to a full-fledged research project that
fulfills many prominent criteria for
being a successful publication so you
will also be interacting with mentors
like me and dr mohit and elia and
understand where and how to find complex
data assets that is going to help you
design a very specific bioinformatics
project and this project as i have
already mentioned can be developed or
can be
designed with an aim to obtain a
research publication by the end of your
trend
so with that i will conclude my
presentation and i look forward to
interact with all of you during the
program and see most of you for the
research fellowship program
and what happened
yes so now i will pass the stage to dr
mohit mazundar to who will talk about
the highlights and curriculum of this
summer
[Music]